no
no no no
no no no
no no
no god no
god please no no no
no i'm gonna read the title of this
video
my dad can't drive me to cincinnati
to meet christina ricci
okay dad i need to i need to get into
cincinnati
okay bye get me a car and i'll get you
you have a car out there you just drove
me home
have a car you hat is your mother's car
i don't have a car oh my god
why can't you drive me to cincinnati you
can
if you give me a car i'll thank you
dad i need to get to cincinnati by a
little
i would thank you it would be really
good to get there by noon
if you get me a car i'll take you i'm
not go
what the [ __ ] dude did i find you a car
to drive
you have a car in a driveway there hat
look at my lips i don't have a car
i don't own a car why can't you talk
dad dad listen listen to me social
security for
850 a month that's
that's not even half of what i have to
spend
on my kids you don't spend anything on
your kids
hello
it
hi how are you you called me how can i
help you
and they hung up because i speak english
because i speak english they hung up
back to the video who
besides the one you pay below minimum
wage to who do you pay for
you're who i don't want to hear me
mentioned talk about another one
twenty dollars an hour is not below yes
it is
twenty dollars in hours what he's paying
him that's not below minimum wage
it's not even that anyway so yes it is
it is it's not that bad you're ignorant
no no the dad's on social security and
is still paying him money
get out of the way i'm going to bed i'm
going to stay up long enough will you
help me or not because i need to be in
cincinnati
he needs to be in splinter artery he
can't even be
kind when he's asking for a favor
if i don't get to cincinnati i'm talking
a lot about you
if i don't get to cincinnati
i'm talking a lot
about you the absolute
unbelievable arrogance of early
look how he's dressed
that was my sister and her husband
picking up their kids
um my older brother living in this house
an
alcoholic he drinks daily on a regular
basis a constant basis he never stops
drinking
excessively excessive amounts of liquors
okay okay lots of liquor by himself in
this house and beats me right in front
of them right in front of my sister
practically
she was in the house one of the times
she was right there standing there
knowing it was happening
he was mad at me that he was beating me
i wasn't doing anything wrong
that was a year ago and now
her one-year-old children are being
babysat in this house
right there with him he's helping
babysit
oh boy here we go sherman's back
brothers and sisters
sherman's back i guess i shouldn't have
but i just don't like addie
this man again
did he hit him with glasses
what is wrong with you idiots you trying
to murder a little child
no jaeger panda stop this royce this is
too much hey bud
there's the door i'm going overtime for
this
i'm trying to murder a child you idiot
sick of him he cheats
addie the man has he's a murderer you
have
felix bear this guy is driving his
family mad i say we get a gofundme for
the family
i would but i want a stipulation that
his brother gets none of the money
i want that stipulation of poor social
security dad gets but his brother gets
none of the money
i'd buy that for a dollar a no earl
clause
you cannot even be the same roof the
first of all threatening violence if
they upset you
fat kick boy scissors this is mine
this is gonna be a date wave thing too
much stuff every once in a while i
always bring up stuff to the main show i
like to have stuff for me am i
loud this will be mine you want to watch
this come watch day wave
addy i'm talking to sheryl pawkway about
this man's behavior
i am talking to sheryl parkway about
do you see his behavior right now do you
see this
oh my god girl
do you recognize he threw glass at him
he threw the glass at his brother
remember his brother's the ones beating
him up and he keeps all of this up he
keeps all of this
up
what are you wrong everybody's sick and
tired
nobody wants to be around you this man
beats me
you threw glass at him in front of his
child
you piece of human garbage
this man beats me but
we have on video throwing glass at him
and now he's bleeding
he's been doing it in the past five
years
i'll clean it up mom
addie that man has a cute mania
what are you [ __ ] kidding me right
now
that is what that psychological
condition is that is a cute mania when a
person
has that it's like manic depression he's
bipolar and he beats me
you threw glass at him you piece of
garbage
is an active issue he continuously has
outburst at the football game
do you see that it was a wine glass it
was a wine glass
a little boy oh wow he's bleeding really
bad
he smashed him with so wait we're
waiting to see footage of his brother
beating him since the beginning of the
saga where it began
and now we're finding out that he threw
glass in his brother's face
i'm transgender okay stop that oh
transgender through classical i cannot
live in a house or he's beating me and
you cannot sit by
shell clockwise cheryl parkway will be
informed of all this she already knows
she already knows you have to stop i'm
not stopping anything because
that's the man is this way and he's in
his house with your
child that's already
this is around christmas folks born let
alone the twins
you are verbally you are
why are you having a meltdown when you
are beating people you just tried to
move a little child
daddy abby addie that is a problem
mom and dad this is a problem no one
should be
less than half that man's side is
getting beat down regularly and it's
happening
it's when i'm in drag addie it's when
i'm you
through this is a current tense
situation
correct you threw a class at him just be
on the level
i'm trying to be on the level daddy this
is a hazardous
environment where i'm getting it if both
of beat down move out because obviously
i'm moving out he's going to be the
problem around your child because he
beats people
he just has you you threw glass at him
you
[ __ ] maniac i have video of him
having a meltdown in front of the child
i have a video of you yeah in front of
my parents
it's not my issue it is
not my issue it's a catalystic issue
based on him
you need to chill you need to realize
that's a problem
where's part two the problem where's
part two
of this
because this is one of three two of
three
here it is just please sit down i need
you i want to vacuum this
[Music]
up stop
i'm not saying you're the only problem
no i'm not any part of this problem i am
a victim and a survivor that is exactly
what
he's a victim and a survivor and the
sisters enabling this horjit
you threw glass in his face
what that is i am talking to you with
dead straight eyes right now that you
are wrong for telling me that i am the
problem
you are a huge part of the problems your
attitude
my attitude is a reaction to getting
beat
down regularly in the house across the
street from you that is not
even the subject you're going to change
it for your own you are trying to give
me the sappy finger thing addie and you
take
from my parents addie i get beat down
in front of them of course i'm gonna
buy my dresses i'm going to buy my
dresses feel free yeah no
that's not what i said no you're turning
into sherman you're making a black and
white that's not that
that's ridiculous they were dressed in
daddy
there were dresses in makeup that i
bought okay so yeah
[Music]
32 he's 32
[Music]
oh
now you want dad to get mad go after his
little girl
yeah dad's all calm and everything but
go after his little girl you
[ __ ] beat the living [ __ ] out of
him
but i am standing right here completely
different problem 32 years old that is
not the reason you're going to use my
number 32 man bleeding
bleeding this man beats me
yes look if you guys want to mirror and
download these videos please do it for
me i just i don't have the
time he just broke this
he has sweater after he that was lying
he beat me and he threw a glass had a
little neck
because they're obvious that you're all
going to good morning hi
you threw glass in his face it is and
she's pregnant yes this is going to
national news what is wrong with you
what evil looks like
this is what narcissism is sherman when
you act so grandiose people
that was so bad uh cheryl parkway if
you're hearing this
you threw the glass
in his face that is assault you piece of
garbage this is awful
you're the only member of the family at
this point that i respect these people
allow this to go on for nearly five
years now while psoriasis
has covered my body it's not very
visible right now because i'm on
treatment for it
um but they're 32 years old
my older brother 32 years old there was
like much larger than me
to beat me down while i'm in track
because he has those kind of outbursts
nobody's uh pulling any like
you know strings on him to do that he's
nuts
sorry i'm just
i'm sad because that kind of stuff
happens around these people
you threw glass in his face
what girl does is this he threatens
[Music]
you do we've seen videos of you going at
people you piece of [ __ ]
and you are evil you are what's [ __ ]
wrong with this country you piece of
[ __ ] garbage
that's not true i go get the camera i'm
recording dad
i'm recording this all right okay so
good morning just go
sit down good morning america sherman
you are a narcissist douchebag
who pushes around his entire family he
threw a class at me
and tried to murder me oh my god did you
see all this that was
one for me you were going at me and that
was wine in my glass
you were going at me and there was wine
in my glass so i threw glass at you
oh my god there was wine in my glass
because he's a six-year-old
psychologically deprived boy good that's
what you just said
that's a jerk right there okay if you
see i dress like a girl i'm a problem
i dress like a girl so my problem yes
yes
the answer is yes
don't ever tell me again these people
are not mentally ill
don't you ever [ __ ] tell me again we
have watched
almost an hour of this saga now no he
beats me down in front of mom and dad
and addie at this point is pretty much
just as bad
complacent the word you're looking for
you 32 year old
abomination in the eyes of god is
complacent
awful just awful this is
a goddamn gold mine
this is a goddamn gold mine
i know earl's going to see this because
earl didn't have many subscribers earl's
going to listen to
every single word that we say here folks
so i'm telling you guys he doesn't have
a big subscriber count and by the way
subscriber count
doesn't change the fact that you should
be ripped apart for the kind of [ __ ]
you're doing hold on a second guys we
might have a break here
give me a second hello
we've been trying to reach you
concerning your car's extended warranty
you should have received something in
the mail about your car's extended
warranty
since we have not gotten a response we
are giving you a
final courtesy call before we close out
your file
press two to be removed and put on our
do not call list
press one to speak with someone about
possibly extend
still connected
[Music]
you know that's the worst when they call
you and then
they don't pick up that's okay sorry
as i was saying earl earl
um
i'm gonna tell you something right now
i know that i want them to call me more
james because i i love when they call me
especially when i'm live on air
just [ __ ] makes my show easier to do
uh
here's what i'm going to say earl
your brother's not wrong you are
mentally ill
earl and the way you talk to your
parents
who support you even though you're 32
years old and should be long gone out of
the house
the way you extort your dad for money
even though you're living in his house
rent free the way you just threw glass
to your brother
because you went after him when they
were having a lovely christmas and you
had to make it about you
is everything that's wrong with this
planet everything that's wrong
you are the worst example
of what a human being is the worst
example
the the worst example
you are a cancer on the society
your parents work their ass off to give
you kids
a life and you don't have the decency to
leave
you treat your mother like garbage and
then after treating them like garbage
you beg them
to drive you to see christina reach you
deserve
nothing but torment and misery
the rest of your life in the 32 years
you have earned a lifetime of torment
and misery
i hope everything in your life goes
wrong
i hope everything you do fails
i hope your parents see the light and
put you out in the streets
i hope because of this you get a
problem which you might already have
i hope when you're living out a street
in heroin
problem in some way you come back
and you realize how terrible you've been
when you've hit rock bottom right
realize man
i was messed up i was wrong and you go
to a church
and and and you because god doesn't talk
to everybody you go to a church
you're on your knees already scuffed
from the psoriasis and being on
trying to blow people for crack and for
heroin i hope you're on your knees
praying to god and you go dear god i was
so wrong
i i was i was so wrong for everything
i've done the way i've treated my family
how terrible i've been as a person
how horrible i've been the way i've
treated the people that
loved me and raised me and gave me
everything in life
and you say please lord will you forgive
me
and i hope god says no
now [ __ ] leave my house of worship
i hope there is no redemption for you
you are the worst human being you
are society
boiled down to its purest form
you are everything that is wrong
with this country with this planet
with human beings in general
i cannot live in a society
where people like you are in charge
i refuse to do it i refuse to do it
okay i don't think sherman ever hit you
but lord do i wish he did do i wish
sherman
upper-cutted you so hard
on this christmas day that you woke up
next halloween now earl
i'll say this because i know you're a
victim and you want attention
i will have you on my show please please
come on my show
i want you to tell me how i'm a bigot
how i'm phobic how your family beats you
i'll let you tell the world i'll let you
tell the thousands of people to listen
i'll let you tell them
on my show you're more than welcome but
please understand
that i'm going to mock you to your core
i am going to make you cry in ways that
you've never
cried before
your garbage you're a narcissistic
piece of human garbage
end quote there you go okay
there you go
because i am absolutely sure once we
post this that sherman is going to be
watching this your piece of [ __ ] dressed
like goddamn johnny depp jesus christ
but pirates of the caribbean over here
what the [ __ ] are you wearing
what the [ __ ] are you wearing all right
um it's it's time it's time for me to to
end look man we
i did give you guys an extra hour today
an extra hour and i'm sure we're not
done